bonjour à tous ça y est microsoft a
enfin dévoilé sa nouvelle console qu'on
connaissait pour l'instant sous le nom
de project scorpio elle a enfin nous
elle s'appelle la xbox one x alors la
xbox monique c'est une nouvelle console
qui s'annonce comme avec la console la
plus puissante au monde et qui va
surtout être là pour rivaliser avec deux
acteurs essentiels d'un côté la
playstation 4 pro la ps4 pro est de
notre côté les pc de gaming même si on
n'est pas sur la même puissance
on va expliquer d'ici quelques instants
quel est le positionnement stratégique
de microsoft par rapport à ses deux
concurrents principaux
comment ils se positionnent qu'est ce
qu'ils mettent en oeuvre pour pouvoir
draguer un petit peu tout le monde et
pour pouvoir gagner de nouvelles parts
de marché on va tout de suite commencé
par présenter cette nouvelle console
[Musique]
nouvelle console qui veulent jours après
effectivement trois années de travail
une console qui a comme point fort de
pouvoir être rétrocompatible avec
l'ensemble du catalogue xbox c'est à
dire que vous ayez des jeux de la toute
première xbox jusqu'à la la xbox ouanès
vous allez pouvoir prendre ces jeux et
les faire tourner sur la xbox one x la
console 4k alors qu'est ce que ça va
pouvoir effectivement changer tout ça et
bien déjà effectivement osé pouvoir
retrouver un peu vos vieux jeu et les
faire tourner sur cette console là ça
peut toujours être un petit plaisir puis
surtout ils vont charger plus rapidement
ils vont avoir une qualité graphique qui
va être supérieur alors ça sera pas de
la 4 car forcément les jeux son pack
audois quatre cadres dont qui
s'afficheront jamais la 4k mais il y
aura quand même une qualité il sera
supérieur à ce que vous aviez pu
connaître avant cette console est aussi
annoncée comme la console la plus petite
au monde dans sa catégorie mais surtout
la console la plus puissante alors on va
tous titres regardez un peu les
spécifications techniques et voir ce
qu'elle a sous le capot au niveau 6
pilloud un cpu à la 8 cores custom amd
cpu cadencé à 2,3 g gars au niveau de
jpy où elle a 6 téraflops la ram c'est
du 12 giga octet gddr5 à 326 gigaoctets
par seconde
le stockage cdu interarmes hdd et il ya
du 8 gigaoctets en mémoire flash
elle dispose également d'un lecteur 4k
blu ray l'audio 6-1 et pas du tout mis
de côté effectivement avec un dts 5.1 on
va retrouver du dolby true hd avec atmo
105 points microsoft annonce de la vraie
katia à 60 images seconde leçon c'est
pareil ils ont vraiment voulu avoir une
immersion complète avec un son
spatialisé une console qui risque de
chauffer mais rassurez vous ils ont tout
prévu il y aura un refroidissement
liquide à l'intérieur ce qui fait que
votre console
elle ne chauffera pas du tout côté
dimensions elle mesure 230 8 de large
par 299 de long et une hauteur de 61 mm
côté poids et pèse 3 kg 8 légèrement
plus lourde de quelques grammes par
rapport à l'aspect s cut pro alors on le
voit un très clairement c'est une
console qui est là pour mettre en avant
de la puissance de la puissance de
calcul de la puissance graphique pour
afficher des jeux qui seront
sensiblement assez gourmand du moins les
jeux qui seront vraiment compatible et
quatre cas qui se rendront donc
j'apprends que cette console calcul très
très rapidement par vous propose
effectivement une expérience de jeu qui
est top
mais surtout le point fort de cette
console c'est vraiment cette
rétrocompatibilité s'esquisser tout à
l'heure effectivement vous allez pouvoir
utiliser vos accessoires et vos jeux ce
qui fait que vous ayez un titre
antérieures qui vous plaisait énormément
mais vous pouvez aussi pouvoir jouer
effectivement un des géants 4 cas sur
une télé en cas de cas là vous pourrez
très très bien tout cumuler sans avoir
besoin de changer de console ou changer
de télé d'autant plus que microsoft
s'annonce vraiment une qualité
supérieure
si vous n'avez pas télé cap cassez vous
avez une télé full hd en 1080p vous
pourrez brancher votre console 4k dessus
effectivement vous aurez une qualité qui
sera quand même nettement supérieur à ce
que vous retrouvez avant sur la xbox one
s d'un point de vue purement marketing
on va très bien effectivement que
microsoft a voulu mettre le paquet sur
la technologie sur la capacité sur la
rapidité sur la puissance et la
performance de cette console donc en
face sony avec sa playstation va
proposer aussi de la puissance 1 à
l'ordre l'intérêt il est double le tout
premier intérêt c'est effectivement de
proposer un produit qui manque un petit
peu dans la gamme xbox microsoft va
faire cohabiter deux produits d'un côté
la xbox one est ce qui est connu du
public et de l'autre côté cette fameuse
xbox one x on va retrouver deux produits
phares d'ailleurs une xbox one est ce
qui risque de décès irait se retrouver à
250 euros baisser un petit peu pour être
vraiment je dirais l'entrée de gamme est
un produit assez abordable alors la
stratégie à l'éclair avec la xbox one s
microsoft cherche effectivement à
séduire les gens qui jouent qui aiment
jouer régulièrement ou de temps en temps
mais qui cherche pas forcément de la
puissance qui recherchent avant tout une
activité ludique pouvoir s'amuser sur
plaisir à
entre coups avec la xbox one x c'est
tout autre chose
microsoft cherche vraiment à draguer et
à conquérir un public de gamer qui est
fan de technologie est fan de puissance
sans pour autant vouloir aller sur du pc
de gamer qui est plus cher microsoft
cherche vraiment à se positionner sur
deux segments
le joueur occasionnel ou joueurs
réguliers sur un segment je dirais
plutôt bon marché et d'un autre côté sur
vraiment le le passionné deming mais qui
veut pas non plus mettre beaucoup
d'argent dans un pc deming c'est donc
une stratégie double que cherche à
mettre en place microsoft tout en
cherchant aussi à contrecarrer les plans
de sony avec sa ps4 pro qui est jusqu'à
présent tout cas la console la plus
puissante en attend effectivement la
sortie de cette console la xbox one x
pour le 7 novembre prochain et qui
annoncé au prix de 499,99 euros alors
effectivement on voit très clairement le
côté marketing du prix psychologique
mais bon un centime près on y ait entre
points forts qui rejoint cette stratégie
les nouveaux jeux qui vont sortir vont
effectivement être optimisé pour tourner
dans les meilleures conditions et avant
la meilleur aspect graphique est la
meilleure vitesse sous la xbox one x
mais ils seront aussi compatibles avec
votre du box one s
c'est vraiment cette fameuse stratégie
double pour pouvoir conquérir je dirais
et draguer une plus large audience
côté technologie sans fil entre on a
effectivement du bluetooth du wifi est
bien trop rouge pour les connectiques on
aura forcément le port d'alimentation de
ports hdmi 3 ports usb 3.0 une sortie
infrarouge un port s pdif et un port
ethernet
il faut surveiller les sorties aussi un
jeu vidéo parce que microsoft annonce de
nombreux jeux à venir et notamment des
jeux vous allez pouvoir jouer avec
vraiment un plaisir 4k donc si vous avez
une télé cap cas vous allez vous éclater
en jeu annoncé il annonce effectivement
force à motorsport cette super lucky
stijl traque donne 3 et 6 of thieves dur
à prononcer sa seahawk 6
donc nous nous veut jeux qui vont
arriver une nouvelle console de la
puissance tout ça dans l'intérêt du
consommateur j'imagine qu'en face sony
avec sa playstation pas forcément à voir
on en reparlera très très prochainement
en tout cas tout ça pour notre intérêt à
nous avec des prix qui baissent si vous
voulez vous faire plaisir à noël vous
allez pouvoir effectivement si vous
voulez pas forcément acquérir cette xbox
os x vous pourriez acheter la xbox one
est normalement moins cher a confirmé à
250 euros ça c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle pour ce faire plaisir et pour
avoir une expérience ludique si vous
cherchez pas forcément de la puissance
sinon à partir du 7 novembre à cette
fameuse xbox live mix à 2 499 99 euros
en attendant dites moi tout ce que vous
en pensez en commentaire hein dites moi
est ce que vous pensez cette console va
être bien est-ce que vous êtes vous par
exemple le choix qui a beaucoup
d'orgueil les commentaires de gamers sur
pc
est-ce que ça me paraît bien est-ce que
vous pensez que même si on n'atteint pas
effectivement la puissance des pc de
gamer on en est quand même relativement
moins par contre pour une console de
salon
est ce que ça vous paraît bien est-ce
que vous pensez que ça va dans le bon
sens ou alors c'est carrément à la
ramasse dites moi tout ce que vous en
pensez en commentaire on en parle merci
d'avoir regardé la vidéo n'hésitez pas à
laisser des jolies pouce si la vidéo
vous a plus haut niveau la chaîne on va
reparler très rapidement de high tech et
de jeux vidéo parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
nouveautés beaucoup de consoles une
grosse actualité dessus donc rester
connecté moi je vous dis à très bientôt
ciao